[Music]
China is facing pressure globally to
crack down on its so-called wet markets
where produce and light animals are
often sold together scientists have
speculated that the current coronavirus
outbreak in humans might have begun at a
market in the city of Iran one
hypothesis is that the virus could have
jumped from bats to pangolins to people
in turn causing a global health
emergency I think I should shut down
those things right away we can clearly
see the great risks to the health and
well-being of the rest of the world as
the virus spread in January China
responded by slapping a ban on the trade
and consumption of wildlife some of the
markets were also temporarily closed in
the months since they've been reopening
with new restrictions but analysts say
it's not yet clear whether China will
really clamp down on what's being sold
inside in the long run
the big question is now that there has
been this temporary ban will it then be
enshrined through an amendment into the
wildlife protection law the devil is
sort of in the details of how you would
then enforce not only the current
measures but also any legal change it's
unclear how many markets were affected
by the ban on trading wildlife but
experts estimate that the markets
selling live wild animals before the
outbreak could have numbered in the
hundreds no one really has been able to
put their arms around quantify the size
of the wild trade mark in the wild meat
market what if you know the the Journal
of nature for example
fairly recently valued it at the wild
meat market at around 7 billion u.s.
dollars then you have the larger
wildlife farming industry and that's
much larger before the outbreak China's
leadership had promoted the wildlife
industry as a way to help rural people
escape poverty shutting down this
multi-billion dollar industry now takes
Chinese officials into difficult
territory they're not just banning
wildlife markets but also closing
thousands of farms where our wildlife
animals are bred which deprives people
of work and income you know especially
those farmers that were raising the 54
species that were allowed to be traded
government should compensate the the
farmers not in the way of money but they
should find alternative livelihood for
these people basically the biggest
public health threat to the country
since the founding of the People's
Republic China in the last 70 years so
the government recognized the tremendous
you know public health impact to 1.4
billion people the Prime Minister's
office decided to end while arbitrate
but also China's National People's
Congress which is a national legislature
issued a ban on wall of the trade and a
wall of consumption but critics say
business are provisional and don't go
far enough the key question is whether
China will adopt the provisional
policies into its legislation that
governs the trade and animals the
wildlife protection law
revisions to the law are expected in the
coming months experts claim it has
contained loopholes for years the three
major parts will make that is a suite
major loop we in the past will protect
the endangered species does not drive we
should write all the world life bourbon
is tourism is manic medicine may be
missed
that's not for eating but that part
should also be controlled should also be
bad if loopholes for using wildlife
products and traditional medicine remain
in place it could mean the trade and
animals continues despite the moves to
clamp down so this industry has been in
the last 40 years able to you know
present to the society certain animal
products to be good for your health good
for fighting cancer it could afford your
beauty good for you know fighting you
know you know sexual dysfunction and so
on so forth Chinese traditional medicine
has been seen as a big driver of the
country's wildlife market overall there
are other concerns about China's ability
to restrict the wildlife industry
critics say too few resources are
available to patrol the industry
adequately and others fear that history
will repeat itself
in 2003 at the height of the SARS
epidemic the government issued a
temporary ban on paths of the animal
trade lightly responsible for the
disease the ban was lifted only a few
months later will it return I would
think yes articulate on the traditional
medicine side and from the perspective
of in the rural areas is quite difficult
to for the government to shut them down
given their importance economically to
different communities and the demand of
also very wealthy people philau the
product that's a that's an uphill battle
and I'm not sure that the party in the
end the government have learned the
lessons of the past from SARS and other
h1n1 other viruses but others say the
unprecedented global impact of the novel
coronavirus may prompt to change in
course what we have a 2003 and they
pushed back and but this time they're
not going to be people more and more
people realize and the cowman team is
never be the faith and the top interest
the government and the majority of the
civil society realize this is not
drawing this pandemic really is a
wake-up call it's different from last
time when after SARS
last time it was certain places wildlife
markets were closed but this time it's
it's going to be different
[Music]